j'en parle avec jean simard qui est
président et chef de la direction de
l'association de l'aluminium du canada
bonjour monsieur simard bonjour d'abord
votre réaction j'imagine que beaucoup de
déception votre côté surtout alors que
le nouvel à ses hommes vient tout juste
d'entrer en vigueur
on n'avait pas de garanties dans le
texte non il n'y a pas de garantie en
fait il faut voir ces deux systèmes
l'heure sur des voies parallèles à
savoir l'accord de libre échange entre
le canada les états-unis et la situation
tarifaire qui repose aux yeux du
président sur des questions de sécurité
nationale
donc deux voies parallèles mais qui
aujourd'hui avec l'entrée en vigueur il
ya quelques semaines à peine de l'accord
de libre échange sont en convergence en
tout cas d'un point de vue canadien
c'est très difficile d'accepter de
comprendre comment on fait pour affecter
d'un tarif du métal qui doit transiter
de part et d'autre de la frontière dans
une cave du libre échange actuellement
et vous dites que c'est contre l'esprit
de la séoune convient toujours de 6000
ouais effectivement parce que non
seulement l'accord de libre échange est
ce qu'il y ait un accord de libre
échange mais qui plus est l'aluminium
comme l'acier d'ailleurs canadien fait
partie des règles d'origine est
obligatoire pour le contenu automobile
alors c'est très je pense que le terme
c'est antinomique le savoir à contre
sens de l'intention manifeste de cet
accord là donc je pense qu'on va avoir
certainement des avenues juridiques qui
vont s'ouvrir dans les prochaines
semaines entre cannes entre le canada et
les états unis est ce qu on pourrait
même parler de représailles parce que je
faisais votre communiqué de presse là où
vous parler maintenant vous demandez
même au canada de considérer le fait
d'aller de l'avant avec des représailles
économiques c'est certain c'est non nos
attentes sont très claires de à
l'endroit du gouvernement du canada
comme ça a été le cas à l'origine il ya
environ un an et demi avec la première
vague de tarifs le canada doit
absolument répondre dollar pour dollar
en verre
importation de produits en provenance
des états unis et ce qu'on prétend nous
c'est qu'il ne faut pas ce sans péché de
considérer plusieurs options incluant
même des produits américains contenant
de l'aluminium on pense ici à de la
bière on pense un et vélo en fait une
série de produits pour lesquels il ya de
la substitution qui existe au canada et
dans l'essentiel il faut dire également
ce que dit dans l'ordre dans l'essentiel
les américains disent que le canada in
hand d'aluminium donc canadien le marché
américain
vous êtes complètement en désaccord avec
ce que disent les américains
actuellement premièrement je fais je
cautionnerais le ces propos là c'est pas
les américains
c'est une entreprise américaine qui a
grand effort de lobby au cours des deux
dernières années a réussi à convaincre
une fois de plus le résident et son sa
gare de rapprocher du bien fondé de
mettre des tarifs pour soi-disant
relancer une industrie moribonde et tout
le monde le reconnaît c'est l'industrie
que les plus au cou au monde pour
produire de l'aluminium
alors ce qu'ils demandent à leurs
gouvernements c'est d'alourdir la
concurrence mondiale pour que je puisse
se maintenir à travers ça c'est parce
que j'appellerais du libre échange c'est
certainement pour une économie de marché
qui cerne qui agitent cette façon de vue
carrément du protectionnisme est ce que
ça vous étonne d'autres enfants au du
tout voilà quel impact quand même ce
sont nos entreprises quels genres de
pertes on pourra entrevoir
écoutez je pense que le premier impact
et c'est jamais très très cristallines
ces situations là le premier impact
c'est la complexification de
l'environnement d'affaires des tarifs
c'est toujours malsain dans un
environnement d'affaires surtout dans
des chaînes de valeur et intégrées comme
par exemple l'industrie automobile nord
américain parce que fois non non ce que
tu es très intégré noah les pièces puis
le mois et la voiture elle passe
plusieurs fois la frontière là
exactement alors là il ya toutes sortes
de considérations à prendre en compte il
faut revoir nos clients
il faut revoir nos contrats comprendre
mesurer les packs rentrer ça dans les
systèmes et refaire un peu sa dynamique
d'affaires pour le produit qui est visé
par ce tarif là parce que contrairement
à la première fois l'oeil est
strictement question d'un produit qui le
lingot de base le pdis vin qui se
produit de ce qu'on appelle de commodité
donc qui sait changer ce revin ou guidée
au gré des jours surtout dans un
contexte d'économie qui est en baisse à
cause du coe veut donc c'était le
dernier recours pour maintenir des
usines ouvertes c'est de revenir à seul
un gaulois qui s'échangent plus
facilement pour lequel on n'a pas un
très beau pays mais qui quand même
permet de faire tourner des opérations
puisqu'on voit ici si vous permettez
d'ajouter c'est ce qu'on voit à travers
le monde dans toutes les usines de
production d'aluminium tout le monde
hop pivoter la production vers du lingot
de base pour pouvoir maintenir les
machines les emplois et écoulé soit sur
un marché qui prenait est-ce qu'on peut
entrevoir aussi des pertes d'emplois
écoutez si jamais il y en avait ce
serait parce que cette situation-là sept
nouveaux cette nouvelle couche de
complexité s'ajoute à une suez qui déjà
très précaire très fragile en amérique
du nord pour notre industrie impliqué
très bas un marché qui est à terre qui
commence à perdre à reprendre du poil de
la bête et donc ce serait pas pour être
la page sur le dos de chameau pour
certaines situations qui déjà était
jugée précaire au frère ennemi
je vous dirais que directement n'est pas
c'est le conservateur américain qui a
encore une fois va faire les frais de ce
cette gestion à la petite semaine de
l'administration de roms aujourd'hui les
américains viennent de consacrer leur
territoire comme étant un endroit dans
le monde où on va payer le plus cher
pour l'aluminium vous avez parlé de
représailles
est-ce que vous avez une poignée
juridique dont du côté
de l'association du gouvernement
canadien également est ce que les
précédents écoutez les mesures de
représailles c'est ce qu'on appelle des
mesures de huit derniers shawn en
anglais mesures de représailles c'est à
dire que on identifie des produits qui
provenant des états unis vers le canada
peuvent être tarifé c'est à dire avec un
tarif de 10 % et faire mal aux
producteurs à la production américaine à
l'économie américaine
puis on essaie de cibler le plus
possible d et roque sont importants pour
l'administration de chaume que ce soit
le royaume le michelin ou d'autres états
comme ceux qui malheureusement vont
faire les frais de cette décision
présidentielle on le vu le canada le
très bien fait la première fois on est
on avait ciblé des produits qui étaient
même hors du champ de l'aluminium pour
s'assurer d'affecter des secteurs
névralgiques
est-ce qu'on va aller jusque là
maintenant ça reste à voir mais le
gouvernement canadien va amorcer une
consultation on a demandé qu'ils mettent
toutes les options sont à table et ce
sera aux ânes ou pire aux autres